[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
happy
yeah
happy trans Tuesday everyone
yeah we were gonna serve tacos
but then they turned into hot dogs
[Laughter]
latest news Target is going balls out
for keeping your balls in
[Laughter]
the retire the retail giant is now
selling women's bathing suits that are
tuck friendly for ladies with penises
I know who knew this was in such high
demand
I always thought shrinkage would solve
this problem
but I guess I didn't realize all these
years how many women were suffering in
silence
wow so pictures and videos of these junk
Tuckers have gone viral Tuckers
spreading spreading like monkey pox at a
pride parade
written by a gay dude on the stairs
yes Tuckers and he will be punished for
that
gay dude loves to get punished
damn that gay guy he tricks me every
time well the Target swimsuits promote
their tuck friendly construction an
extra crotch coverage things I always
look for in a thong
although why would
why would you hide the fact that you got
a package at the beach unless you want
to trick someone sorry I'm never going
to be comfortable if a girl is staring
at me and getting noticeably aroused in
her swim trunks
that goes for the beach and women's
bathrooms
that was funny when it was written
several people
several people online have said targets
marketing to kids but a spokesperson
claims they're only offered in adult
sizes which sucks because my nephew's in
third grade and he's a C cup
in response to the backlash Target's own
CEO said these moves are good business
decisions and it's the right thing to do
for society but really good for business
Mr CEO then why were some southern
stores reportedly asked by Target to
move the merch away from the front of
their stores
one target Insider telling Fox News
digital they've been having emergency
calls with management to Tamp down the
displays
so here's the deal no one is saying
trans people don't exist or don't
deserve rights or bikinis we're just
saying maybe corporations might stop
using baby clothes to push some
delusional cultural Trend or or to
indulge in political exhibitionism just
to place yourself high on an activist
score card
because that's what it is I mean have
you noticed all these things keep
happening one after the other as if it's
coordinated the Canadian trans teacher
with dartboard size nipples remember
that trans swimmers and Runners beating
their biological female competition like
rented mules Dylan mulvanian is 365 days
of being a girl culminating in a Bud
Light ad campaign that made the
Hindenburg look like a gender reveal
party
that Adidas Pride campaign featuring a
male model in a one-piece bathing suit
meant for women I was so offended I
personally reached out to the model and
told him so over dinner in Aspen he
really
he appreciated the flowers
of course there are kids cartoons and
books featuring perky non-binary male
characters in dresses talk about Looney
Tunes drag queens popping out from
behind School library aisles like little
gate Jack in the boxes it's as if drag
queens are the only adults who can still
read
meanwhile sororities are feeling feeling
the Bulge as Kappa Alpha goes alpha male
you got a six foot two 260 pound trans
sorority sister allegedly trying to fool
her sisters into thinking she's not
really a man sorry that's a man and it
takes it's going to take a lot of beer
goggles for him to hook up at the next
formal luckily Bud Light is really cheap
right now
but all of this is trans related it's a
culture War Blitzkrieg and it raises the
world's most important question
how does it affect me Greg Gutfeld
it doesn't really I don't wear bikinis
unless Kudlow demands it
but I'm a social commentator with a lot
of time I'm in my hands which is good
for you but bad for Target fact is I
never shop at Target it always struck me
as a Kmart for extras from Glee
but when this happens I keep asking
myself have we reached Peak trans yet
they got swimsuits the cover of the
swimsuit issue you got pop singers and
track stars and swimmers and now even
Mass shooters
so they are now as American as you can
get which means like the rest of us they
got a Target on their back it's called
humor they should embrace it
[Applause]
financial analyst Heather
he's closed more clubs than the
coronavirus comedian Joe DeVito
she's like a cigarette butt small white
and often founded crime scenes Fox News
contributor captive
[Applause]
and finally he uses sleeping bags for
socks my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
[Applause]
and there you claim to be a business
Expert and so I'm very curious about
this so-called woke capitalism uh is it
simply because they really care about a
community or just trying to score points
so that somehow they could get more
advertising well I heard you mentioned
this in the monologue that CEO Brian
Cornell has been on a tour defending
this decision
um unlike you see the bad business
decisions of of Nike and Bud Light it's
affecting their bottom line these woke
policies that HR departments are coming
out with uh they just want to make sure
as a company you're not a target of
being called homophobic racist Aegis
sexist or any of the other boxes and by
checking that off he's doing himself a
disservice in the raw in the long run
you're not catering to your customer
most Americans who shop at Target the
the parents think this is wrong they
understand well what everybody thinks
everybody do you ever meet anybody real
people that are like going this is great
well they and Target's defense they said
oh it's not for kids we're not targeting
kids we're targeting adults nobody wants
to see this this is a policy of bad mark
marketing strategies it started back in
2014 same-sex marriage they got behind
Okay then they got behind uh 2017
removing gender from the store you can't
have a section for boys can't have a
section for girls and then in 2017
opening up the women's bathroom to well
I guess anyone so you're going further
down the rabbit hole customers are going
to boycott which is too bad I like
Target I want to go to Target
everybody's in on it everybody's in a
KKK just came out with a rainbow sheet
for June
uh Joe you were trans before it was
popular and yet you're
which is weird because you're very
unpopular still
wow wow is there a question that comes
just abuse yes was Joe Mackey busy
anyway what do you make of this
are weren't any there were actual
onesies for Pride I don't really care
about that except we do know kids don't
make these decisions somebody else is
doing it so they have like children
sized shirts about you know uh um
promoting the trans lifestyle I guess
and I assume that's harmless again
though you're turning your children into
social social issue Billboards yeah I
don't like it when they do that any of
the kids where they they make them uh
come forth with a political opinion and
well they did at least say that those
swimsuits were for adults I bought one
with the extra room
um I
I was wearing it backward yeah yeah but
I think what they're saying now is that
pouch is actually for your light beer
in there it I yeah I don't know if we've
reached Peak with this it but this has
nothing to do with social issues it's
this weird way of virtue signaling
getting a high ESG score I would say if
you don't like it don't shop there I
don't know I kind of like Target but if
you don't want to buy your clothes at
Target you know buy your clothes at
Walmart where they people transition to
not giving it yeah
that's me all over
cat it is pretty interesting though it's
like it all happened kind of
at once like we're seeing it everywhere
it's it's almost as though it's a it's
it's like the extra part of a recipe for
every story ah this we've done this
story before no
trans and now we have a trans story why
do you think this is happening I know
where where all the ladies put in their
penises before exactly
exactly I okay so I spent a long time
today because of you yeah uh on the
Target website looking for the tuck
bathing suits which by the way I'm sure
that's just going to totally destroy my
algorithm for the rest of time
it's been especially because it probably
like already has the rest of my
measurements
um but I None of the bathing suits that
have the tuck friendly tag on them that
I saw on Twitter actually said anything
about tuck friendly on the website
interesting isn't it interesting it just
said sticks out it just said Pride which
like I'm not gonna make the jump from
Pride to there you put your penis in
here yeah
imagine if you like someone might just
order it and all of a sudden they
realize oh they ordered a banana hammock
on accident
I look at this I'm sure it's happened a
lot
there is male underwear that does that
right that has like a separate little I
don't have a penis I know I know
I know it is strange I know I sound like
I do
you're mid-transition no I'm not I'm all
woman you are
um Tyrus what do you make of this I'm a
penis Pride shirt might be cool I don't
know but I just probably won't want to
pick it up at Target that's what
Spencer's is for yeah
why can't we just have a section mm-hmm
if it's you know just have a a
transection yeah since it's such a big
Market yes just put it in every store
men women trans what's what's the issue
that can give them their own section
yeah and we just move on with it again
doesn't because it's not about that it's
not about trans people having
opportunities to find clothes it's about
virtue signaling yeah and that's the
part that sucks for Trans people who are
just trying to live their life and if
they're quietly going to store trying to
get a bathing suit or whatever do they
need to be in the front everyone needs
to see them buy it yeah you know it's
like or they need to have at least a
social section where you can have like
redneck t-shirts BLM t-shirts LGBT
teacher it's like just the whole where
everybody can go fantastic idea yeah the
offense yeah it would be I mean it's
like the stranger section yeah you get
mega and you got
Mega
yeah maggot next to Peta yeah all the
little birds are all together yeah but
they won't make a section because the
CEO Brian Cornell knows there's
virtually no target market for this
there are a few people yes but most
Americans that shop there are not going
there for tuck your private parts in
your bathing suit clothing how ironic
that Target has no target yeah
yeah
it is ironic you know I've said it so
many times before the only solution is
nude beaches yes you have said that you
have just be a bunch of beaches with
guys looking around let their watches
going when are they coming yes
yes all right I think we've done enough
here hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else